[Music]  Khloe Kardashian welcomed an healthy  baby girl on April 12th and the  Kardashians can't help but gush over  their newest family member Kylie Jenner  was the first relative to publicly  congratulate Khloe on her first child  sharing a snapchat video Thursday with a  pink filter that read Congrats Khloe  it's a girl baby baby baby mama Kris  Jenner reposted that funny video of  kendall Jenner captioned blessed then  there's Kourtney and Kim the sisters  were spotted touching down in LA after  flying in from Cleveland where et  learned they were both in the delivery  room with Coco and apparently Kim took  on a pretty big job during the birth on  Friday she tweeted quote Khloe  Kardashian your baby girl is so  beautiful I'm so happy I was able to  return the favor of holding your leg  while you pushed earlier this month Kim  told et she was helping Khloe get ready  for motherhood unlike the real one with  her if like what goes down how it's  gonna go down  [Music]